this valley is the western border of
peru's minus national park which
stretches from the Andes to the
Amazonian lowlands we've come here
together with the team from the
Frankfurt zoological society we want to
find out more about one of the shyest
animals in minus the Andean bear Roxanna
raucous is installing camera traps to
capture images of the shy omnivores and
she finds signs of them cast a las
marcas nello soak at the palace tiara
the marks of a bear that climbed up into
this tree hey ese lugar en esto de punta
das you can just see where he clawed
into it his for applause latched on here
so he could get up the tree but I saw
everything another one no there are
signs on the forest floor as well
tenemos a quitarme la se says here are
some droppings and you can see the small
seeds asme a clear everywhere the Andean
bear disperses seeds from plants in its
droppings so it plays an important role
in this ecosystem but time and again
there are conflicts with farmers when an
Andean bear gorges itself in their corn
fields the bears are skillful and the
damage for the farmers is great a las
dos Quinze estamos grande o na desde que
lo que es este por ejemplo no vemos el
my isla forma como los here or hue marks
that show how the bear eats the corn he
does it just the way we do ah Bertie
first he uses his paws and removes the
Cubs with his claws sometimes he leaves
the cobs in you can see the bear's claw
marks very well laughs gareth to protect
the Andean bear the Frankfurt zoological
society is offering people alternatives
to farming
weaving is an art of interest designers
around the world and it can bring in
more money than agriculture no solamente
ya Stengel nah not only do they earn a
higher income with it to the employer on
yeah but they can also depict the menu
National Park biosphere reserve in their
textiles especially the animals you find
here ahsoka song art edittext eel and
only when the Andean bear is no longer
seen as a nuisance but instead as a
species deserving protection will its
survival be assured